at this point in your career
you obviously can get actors that you're
interested in
i when you're writing a script are you
envisioning certain actors
in these roles early on i
i do i i try to fight that instinct
because
it's it's a little unhealthy to do that
for me
um uh but it's sometimes it's a nice
north star to have of kind of like if
someone represents a type of buoyancy or
a type of comedy or something like that
aiming towards that is
helpful but i try to keep my mind really
open like
i make lists of names of of the types of
people that i'm looking for but
honestly i've now come done this so many
times that i i try to be as organic as
possible and go hey
the right person to play kevin wendell
crumb will come into my life
and at the right time that person will
emerge and so james mcavoy will come in
and whoever that is and in this case
vicky and gael
and all the wonderful actors in this
movie kind of
came at this moment in their in their
lives and are up for doing the kind of
filmmaking that i asked for which is
very
you know specific and demanding we were
we rehearse intensely it's very
choreographed almost like a dance
um there isn't really any coverage so
it's like theater and
some of the shots are minutes long and
you you have to just go with it like
theater and so it's a very different
kind of
you really have to give yourself over
and and not protect yourself
listen i would imagine you there's a lot
of choices that you could do
in terms of making what you want to make
um why this
project over something else wow what an
interesting question i have there's a
tug an
urgency that comes when i when i think
of an idea or in this case if i read
something
um that becomes irrational it just it
becomes i
i have to i have to tell this story i'm
not sure what it is about that story
that makes me need to tell it
that right that second um and it's a
it's a big commitment you know it's an
18 months to two year commitment so it
needs to be irrational um
and i i think maybe the cinematic
opportunities or the
or the emotional opportunities or
philosophical opportunities or
combination of all those three
make it so that irrationality happens
and in this in this case when i read
that graphic novel
it was what was on my mind you know my
parents are getting older my dad's
struggling with dementia
and this was what's on my mind and i i
need to
to work it out and um spending two years
working it out and having cinema uh
the tools of cinema sound and atmos
sound and
and and shooting on 35 millimeter and
doing long angular dolly tracks and
camera movements that are independent of
the characters to show kind of
the kind of heartlessness of time as it
no matter what's happening to you all
those things felt
important to me you mentioned you shot
on 35
at this point is it more expensive to do
film
like how much i guess what was your
reasoning for film
i i mean i love it i love film i love
what it does there
is something about shooting in a
environment like a beach or with water
that only film can capture and when you
do with digital
it has a coldness to it it's almost
because
i don't know why maybe because you're
looking at something so organic as
sand and water and film is a chemical
you know interaction and there's
something there about the organic nature
of that i don't know what it is
but film allows you to feel the most
important things about looking out at
the ocean
or looking at a beach whereas digital it
almost has coldness of
everything's equal the the in for too
many details and you don't know what to
look at
it's in its limitations that film is so
beautiful
i mean for me i i'll uh it's never never
a question
film is the best way but it is more
expensive to shoot
considerably more expensive to shoot on
film and in this movie we shot it during
a pandemic and there's only really two
labs in the united states that even do
it
and the pandemic was shutting new york
and la down and we there was a real
chance that we would have undeveloped
negative for the entire
shoot so it was just insanity i don't
recommend shooting on film during a
pandemic but
i had i honestly had not thought that
about
what you just said that the pandemic
would make it so you couldn't develop
the film couldn't develop
i know we were we had you know worst
case scenarios
all planned out fridges this what are we
gonna do if we have
you know canisters of undeveloped film
in the caribbean
what if there was a power outage you
know like you you we need a generator on
top of you know
a million things had to be thought about
i'm so i i can't believe your producers
let you shoot film
until luckily yeah luckily it's just my
money so it worked out i was
i was the insane insane person risking
it and
listen this this could have been a real
cautionary tale that you'd be talking
about going did you hear what happened
to
tonight when he tried to pay for his own
movie in the caribbean during the
pandemic and
the whole half his movie melted this is
actually
the other thing i wanted to address with
you i had heard that you had been paying
for your recent movies
yourself yeah i am curious um talk which
movies have you actually paid for
and at what point does like your wife
say to you no
you know here i i paid for the visit
split
glass and and old all four of those and
i pay for servant as well
and and and the reason that i do it is
to to do it at the smallest number where
i can be
um free and i can do something
provocative and different and unusual
and i'm not putting my partners at risk
i'm i'm taking the risk
and uh in most scenarios because we're
doing it at such a small price
we're gonna be okay you know no matter
what and so we can make the most
most interesting art i don't have to
think about it some equation of safety i
don't i don't have to think about that
and i believe the flip happens where the
audience can feel
that it's different that there's no
safety valves on it there's no safety
guard rails on it
they can feel that it's been there's no
supervision and it's like this kind of
you know free spirited thing i i believe
audiences can feel that and that's why
they've been coming to these movies
so how does it work so you're
essentially like with universal
distributing this
yeah uh do they have any sort of um
can they really give you notes or
they're signing on to be like the
distributor of your movie
uh it's super healthy uh it's
they are signed on to be the
distributors it's my movie but they
they i ask them to give me notes
whatever you want to give me i don't
have to do them
but you get i want you to give them to
me they're healthy smart partners so we
have a really
great relationship in that in that way
it's very respectful
i really look to them for advice um
i can get lost you know i'm so intensely
looking at something for two years i
need my
my my brothers and sisters at universal
to help me
sometimes you know do that so it's been
it's been a great relationship of giving
them something very
uh daring um but but they've
helped me achieve what i want to achieve
i got to stop there i'm just going to
say
again at some point please let me talk
to you about the ending
and have a fantastic day doing the rest
of your interviews all right buddy take
care